ce qu'ont subi des pressions bah en fait
pour être tout à fait honnête avec vous
je crois qu'il ya aucun patron aucun
ministre qui osent m'appeler sur mon
téléphone portable parce qu'ils sont
tous persuadés que j'enregistre toutes
mes conversations téléphoniques et là
dessus d'ailleurs je vais laisser un
léger flou peut-être que c'est vrai en
fait les pressions s exerce plus tôt
là-haut tout là-haut à la direction de
france télévisions et la plupart du
temps bas on n'en parle pas donc c'est
plutôt un bon signal de la part de
france télévisions nous laisse
travailler tranquillement après il ya
quand même de l'intimidation de grosses
sociétés qui ne veulent pas nous
accorder des interviews et qui font tout
pour que nos enquêtes ne sortent pas
mais ben comme vous nous connaissez ça
nous donne plutôt envie de les sortir